foreign
yesterday was Independence Day as we've
mentioned that was kind of a poignant
moment for us it ended with uh the most
amazing uh firework show I've ever seen
oh my God by far by far I was not
expecting that we lived in a you know an
island small town I was expecting a
little fireworks display which would be
kind of cool if this was all the way the
four of us like whoa what happened but
earlier in the day
um
uh
we moved into a place that had a garden
that was fully overgrown when we moved
in and that Garden you have been
resurrecting uh at a flower garden not a
food Garden right not a food Garden but
a flower garden that to me looked like
it was gonna be it was going to need to
be just
totally dug up and new stuff put in
there was it was overgrown but the
person who had initially put it in was
quite a thoughtful person apparently a
very yeah the woman whose home it was
um before she died who was who's now she
died in her 80s yeah uh but she she was
apparently an amazing woman an amazing
woman apparently maybe a pilot yeah uh
anyway a person with an incredible life
story who had obviously put I think she
had tremendous gardening insight and um
sort of you know the the approach so far
has been get rid of the obvious things
that we don't want the grass that shows
up yeah and and just and wait and see
what else and see what else will come up
and it's been remarkable it's been
remarkable so anyway uh there's this
little miracle that has emerged this
spring for us it's our first spring in
the place and
um
you know we knew we had hummingbirds
which is cool there's only a couple of
species of hummingbirds up here but
they're both you know all hummingbirds
are cool and these guys are especially
uh behaviorally interesting
um and anyway the garden has become a
little Paradise for bumblebees and
hummingbirds and so anyway uh I I love
photographing hummingbirds and I haven't
done very much in the tempered Zone
because
there aren't it's just hard to do yeah
but in our garden it's become possible
so yesterday uh I decided to see if I
could capture hummingbirds But It's
tricky in our garden because in most
Gardens there's like a plant that
attracts hummingbirds if you can spot it
you can set up on a tripod get ready for
the bird to come and if you're lucky you
get it in our garden you never know
where the bird's gonna be because
there's so much going on there's a lot
there are a lot of species the
hummingbirds go for but there's also
what seems to be their favorite is this
toad flax and we've got just a lot of
spiers of toad flax so anyway yesterday
I decided to see if I could do it
handheld I would just figure out where
the bird was and see if I could catch it
and Zach do you want to show I got a
bunch of really good pictures but anyway
um so I believe this is a female Rufus
hummingbird and a Rufus hummingbird is
an amazing animal they're migratory
route is from deep in Mexico and they
range up to Alaska oh my God in the
summer
um so anyway they're all do you know are
all the populations
um migratory or some of them residents I
believe all of them are migratory I'm
not an expert on this species but that's
what I think is going on here and so
here you have this beautiful female
hummingbird drinking nectar from this
toad flax uh in this amazing Garden
planted by this now now gone uh but very
insightful woman and I I think it's
pretty clear that she was fond of
hummingbirds herself and planted uh to
attract them
so anyway I thought I would wonderful
apologize for the people who are just
listening
um
but this is a beautiful animal it is uh
what a privilege to get to see them yeah
what a beautiful photograph right thank
you nice to see it on Independence Day
too that felt right yeah
thank you
[Music]